welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz today I'm
joined by just in the person who is the
founder of hive a management consultancy
helping recruitment owners that want to
scale and grow the equity value of their
McCrimmon business and previous to this
Justin was the founder of a recruitment
business called human capital which he
exited through an MBO in 2017 Justin
thank you for joining me venuceane thank
you for inviting me on and that's been
then I know I normally always say this
but I am really looking forward to this
conversation obviously and kalpesh can
be introduced us and sort of said the
sort of the sort of mission you're on
right now feels like it could
potentially give a lot of value to the
listeners and kalpesh to be involved in
the podcast already so it's been great
to sort find out more about you and your
journey because I think it's unique and
something that I think a lot of people
can learn and get a value from so I'm
really excited to dig into it but where
I always like to start on this podcast
Justin is how did you enter the world of
recruitment well it's a while ago knows
in the in the late 90s
I mean basically did uni when traveling
probably a bit too long I was away for
about three years finally came back and
I had to never clue what I wanted to do
as a job my father trained as an
accountant he he suggested that I might
want to try that if I didn't know what I
wanted to do I didn't really want to do
that's gonna sleep but yeah and I went
to long one a places I went to try and
get a job as a trainee accountant was I
went to Michael Page to see if they
could help me find a job yeah sort of 30
seconds into the into the interview the
interviewer actually lady bike copilot
Kirsten McLeod who is still recruiting
today said you don't wanna be any
I'll get my cake and an actually stood
out have you thought about recruitment
and it kind of went from the classic
line that changes people's lives about
recruitment I'm a saved accounted page
and what and what what type of business
did Michael page it like at that point
and then in the late 90s so it was
completely london-based they were based
in Parker Street which is in Holborn
they weren't there they're on two floors
of the three floor building three or
four court building there was about
probably 70 of us 8t living Wow it's
pretty small mm-hmm and I in fact was in
the team I sat next to Steve Ingham who
is now the chief executive Wow
I said next to his team he was the
manager of the marketing team and I was
in the public sector team awesome and
yeah it all grew familiar I didn't like
I didn't know what was yeah it's one of
those sliding door moments yeah how old
was you at that point when you entered
the I was 24 24 okay
24 end up in Michael Page huge brand and
obviously ended up working there from
what consumer month four years rule
solid stint in terms of your first job
and recruitment
I mean people people have always said on
this podcast that ended up at Michael
Page your s3 or a business like that
that sort of the training the
environment you get exposed to and the
people that you meet have a rule end up
having a real dramatic impact on sort of
your career long term so in hindsight so
I guess sort of sort of round up those
first four years how was it working for
them how were those first four years for
you
oh it's tremendous I mean Paige back
then was was it was a great company and
still is probably but but certainly back
then it was it was French as a sportsman
worked hard we played hard it was
competitive yeah as if internally but in
a very positive way
it was definitely competitive externally
we yeah we wanted to beat the
competition which of those back in those
days was companies like Robin Walters
and and the training was great it was
hard work it was an eight too late
environment 8 a.m. to 8 p.m. Monday the
Thursday yeah and you were expected to
be there you expected to be putting in
the yards but if you if you were good at
it and and you worked hard you got
rewarded well and I made some cracking
friends which I still have today I made
some great contacts people that I still
talk to rely on work with on occasions
you know individuals that are actually
or and individual that actually invested
in me and human capital years later
amazing it's I was so lucky it was one
of those moments and and Paige been like
s3 back in the day as well Paige was a
hotbed of entrepreneurs yeah you can go
back and look at the whole the telephone
directory be able to see oh look they're
so well and so in your four years
they're just quickly did you just say a
bidding consultant or did you so it will
become a leader did you get some
leadership because I was building it so
I take attempts for two years
okay into the public sector and then
permit qualified accountants into
innocent commerce companies in postcode
wt2 w14 okay love that and then so how
did you why did you then start human
capital I mean what what yeah what would
where did that come from
how was I I left Paige regular left page
I knew I wanted to do something sorry
different I was I really enjoyed my time
there but
no I didn't want to be part of this of
the pays machine sure going forward well
for two months long there I had a I had
a desire to that point time I had desire
to sort of try and find a work-life
balance because I was really you really
were burning both ends the camera and my
father actually it was an independent
he'd worked for London Business School
and he was then independent and he
seemed to have a really nice laughs I
worked hard but they had long holidays
and yeah so I actually set myself up to
train recruits us to be recruiters
really yeah so I did that for I think
around about through about three years
and during that time one of one of my
clients had a change of management and
that management that chief exec bought
in a dot-com business to this
bricks-and-mortar a Reuben company this
was in the early 2000s the dot-com boom
and he actually the few exec asked me to
join him and again it's one of those
moments and it only happened in the
dot-com boom he asked me to come in and
manage a floor right around a hundred
recruiters I have no management
experience oh my god but I was how old
was I would have been if the page there
would have been about 30 old and yeah 32
and yeah it was it was it though they
were crazy times calm boom everybody
thought they were gonna be a calm
billionaire from there and we certainly
thought we would sort of cracked it we
hadn't but we learned I learned an awful
lot in doing that job yeah
and it's it's after doing that and and
all the living there I I eventually
decided that it I probably wasn't the
right guy to keep doing the job I was
doing so I but I knew I didn't want to
go and work for another company yeah
that's the crucial thing I I've been my
own boss with the trading company I kind
of been my own boss or part of a wreck
tight-knit management team
with with a calm recruiter and I knew if
I could if I could I really wanted to do
my own thing yeah yeah you had a taste
for it and just like years no way that
yeah yeah yeah I made sense and I was
very fortunate that one of my other
clients which is a company that became
hydrogen so got set up by in Temple and
Chris Cole and financed by trap called
Charles Marshall the three of those guys
invested excuse me they they were big
client of mine in training yeah yeah and
they invested in me to set up human
capital so they they were my business
angels well I
relatively speaking I didn't have two
coins to rub together and but they they
saw some potential in me that Guinness
and they agreed to provide me with
startup capital - so did you so did you
start just a bit of context then to help
me and people is did you start human
capital on your own as a solo founder no
there was a chap that I'd worked with at
the dot-com McGruder and I approached
him and I said look I'm I'm thinking of
going down this reason I want to set up
a would you like to join me if you cut
you in on the business be great to work
with you eccentric cetera and yeah
the two of us January 2003 - over sat in
an office off of Fleet Street there were
a bunch of other people that were
supposed to join us didn't they didn't
tell them I noticed my garden Lee was
quite long and by the time my darling it
was over these other people had fell
found other jobs we've literally just me
and Nick sat up as each other in an
office for 12 and there's just two of us
first thing we did was renegotiate our
lease and then we said about trying to
make some money so just quickly then
what was the relationship with the
investors was it just in that we believe
in you we see
unity his a rural injection of cash to
sort of catapult you and your plans or
was it sort of on see equity was it sort
of financials and also advisory and
central mentorship and sort of advice or
oh it's definitely the letter has
definitely left I mean the money was
there
and they were very good at providing the
finance to get us off the ground but we
were profitable within within twelve
months in fact at the end we broke even
the end of 12 months and within in the
second year we were we were turning a
profit
we were cash positive and in fact by the
end of the second year we paid back the
below this is actually a loan was a loan
frequency you know we'd pay back the
loan so what how does that work sorry so
it was they lent you money in return for
X percentage of the business yeah and
when you paid it back what that then
reduced or didn't stay the same market
they kept they kept their cut quite
Rolly I mean I honestly I mean you know
I could not have done what I could not
achieve what I achieved without their
backing both the financials in the area
days but actually their support and
advice over the years now there Chris
Chris and Charles Charles had retired by
that point I was living abroad in an
in-sample and Chris Cole they were
building what became hydrogen so in I
had access to them and we talked
relatively frequently and sort of with
but actually as their business grew and
my business grew we spend less and less
time together but there was this yeah so
all the way through just quickly I mean
there's loads of companies out there now
that invest in the back people like
Justin Pierce and they're bigger than
your journey just just in hindsight this
quickly why do you walk why do you think
they saw potential in you what did you
demonstrate what sort of I don't know
I'll be interested sort of get your
thoughts on that because I think that's
something that I don't know people could
get value or be interested
why why they thought you'd be a great
person to be involved with
well I'd actually worked with Chris at
page so he knew me and panicked and then
having trained their people for them and
it's called finest professionals that
style having trained their guys for two
two-and-a-half years they're gonna knew
what work I did there so I think they I
think to answer questions then they knew
me very well yeah trust as Trust doesn't
good man I trust you who the quality to
work they knew they knew my my values
they understood my values mm you're very
aligned in the way we felt about not
just business but life itself
and you know I think it was still a big
deal for them to put their hands in
their pockets and because you know
there's no guarantees but I think that
probably really helped in their decision
yeah sure and yeah I think it's really
it's really challenging if you give you
if you're an investor and you're looking
for finance my advice would be try and
find finance from a source that can
you're going to go to private
individuals private individuals that can
actually add value and value your
business as well I wasn't just an
injection of cash yeah yeah rock rather
than just seeing you as a as a bit of a
roulette wheel actually they do want to
get involved in your business mmm that
startup in I mean you know you might
change as you get and that startup and
actually having access to somebody who
has a vested interest in your business
of this interest in they're doing well
and I've got experience that you can
draw from that's a that's a real price I
think hmm so I guess just for context
then human capital what what markets did
you recruit in early on what was the
actual business itself I'm sure that
changed but just content oh it did okay
so we started off
we started off with routing in in risk
so risk analysts and credit risk risk
etc for financial institutions and yeah
but as with you know in many situations
and being a being entrepreneurial minded
an opportunity arose with a client this
client was actually in the energy and
energy business and the parent gas
business yeah the trader that's right
and we got to know them and they don't
say look can you recruit traders and I
said never done one before but yeah we
can recruit we can do anything doesn't
matter what you're looking for we can
find them and they gave us the job I
think they actually retained as we have
a small retainer fee upfront as oh and
and we just worked our backsides off to
fill that job that job we then actually
fill we replace the person we took out
we replace that person with another
person money so the classic domino fill
and then I turn around to my business
partner and say look I'm I really enjoy
this front office trading malarkey I'd
like to concentrate on this if you want
to concentrate on the middle office risk
stuff I'm going to concentrate on is
rating stuff and actually then a few
months later I said look I think we
should actually just focus on power and
gas or energy and energy trading and not
work with banks in front of in FX or in
whatever sort of just sit on that point
before we move on what sort of Mars what
sort of milestones did you hit for you
to have confidence that it was actually
a market that you want to dedicate all
your resources to or focus on good
question I think what I think in
retrospect and I think I thought this is
a time I think in retrospect I it was
all about the fact that here was a
market that was growing so this was a
market that was on
on the up yeah the energy sector was was
deregulating in Europe and also in the
States
these were there were roles that where
they were relatively junior individuals
and quite a lot of them but they were
very highly paid mm-hmm
there was a lot of demand it was also at
white market that you could get to know
you get your arms around
where it's not quickly yeah so then if
you wanted a [ __ ] a gas trader you have
to go and find another gas trader you
couldn't take somebody from outside of
guess trading okay Canada population was
relatively small yeah try some ions of
that I'm sure and if you if you work
really hard to wrap your arms around
that and own the own is it's a big thing
because easy thing for me is good
recruiters is I didn't when this phrase
but good recruiters worked i markets did
recruit about tight markets if you can
put your sent yourself or the center
your company at the center of a time
market and you know the all the
stakeholders you have a relationship
with all the stakeholders the candidates
the clients or sometimes they wear both
hats and you're seen as the conduit for
recruitment for hiring for talent then
you you're in a very strong position and
you don't need to be everything to all
people I think I think had some remote
recruiters sort of have this idea that
yeah you have to be able to provide all
sorts of different services mmm you know
pick one or two things and do them
really really well I've been known for
doing them all really really well and
that that will provide you with a very
strong foundation to then build your
business out from those you've got
really strong foundations that you can
grow up otherwise if you start if you
have all over the place it gonna be how
different is that to sort of really
focusing on a niche a niche niche we're
gonna call it the inch wide mile deep is
out there so don't get caught going
toward more
yeah and that's the opportunity that you
recognize so how many years was that in
looking around so that at human capital
what whereabouts was this on the journey
that was about that was probably by the
end of year to enter via - okay cool so
obviously so obviously achieved the MBO
in 2017 so let's just sort of break this
down a bit so maybe less or break this
down into maybe the first five years of
HC you just spoke about there we're sort
2 or so years and then found up see the
niche grow market and type market you
said what how did the business then
evolved from that point and what did the
business end up looking like towards
when we get to this or five-year mark
and I guess what was going on and what
the things that like yeah so working a
tight market the the strategy that that
that I came up with was actually if you
were the Thai market you go into a
company an energy trading company and
you start working for them in gas
trading in London so you're hiring gas
Fraser say yeah and then you know you
inch-wide mile-deep so you're going into
that the company is the inch or the
entry you go into this company I wanna
go mile deep into them okay
we then would look to to recruit power
traders electricity traders then all the
traders or whatever whatever other
traders trading level so we never
dropped below a certain level which
would be a search firm that was three
levels we were never really went below
sort of 3540 and most of our fees would
have been in the 60 70 80 grand most of
your fees yeah really
in that sort of area very limited space
okay so what was your average forget
that Thea that point I would have been
probably around about 3540 Wow but yeah
it did the best bets that that sort of
was the level that we went in at and
then if you go into a company say this
energy trading company
we would the strategy was to try and
find as many of those types of roles
those that level of role as possible
yeah and by proving to the client that
we were great at search not greater
funny gasps traitor the greatest search
they were there's a difference
well if you're great at finding
castrated we can do this one yesterday
so your great rolodex gas traders and
yeah I can't we what we always aim to do
is we have say was I it was our search
process that found was the gas traders
for you it wasn't that fact that we've
got this great rolodex although we do
actually we've developed this really
strong professional recruitment process
which we can now apply oh you need a you
know a head of power trading we haven't
got a background we have a lot of
rolodex and penetrating uh what we have
is a proven methodology for finding
these people and you benefited from that
in this high we did two over there now
would you would you would you trust us
to do this because in doing so and this
is what we did we persuaded these
companies to users across their
businesses and then we developed that
rolodex of power traders we then
persuaded them to users in all trading
we developed so this is the mile deep
piece and then and then you're able to
take that expertise and market it to
other companies that you are experts in
gas power yeah so we did that we built
we built our capability in all the
energy products in in Europe in fact
because as a year others London and then
it wasn't consecutive it blurred but we
then right okay so this company acts
let's call it BP I can that which has a
big trading business they they obviously
don't just operate in London they
operates in Chicago how come here yeah
how come again those back at four so we
then said right we'd love to do work for
you in those locations too would you
trust us to do an oil trading search in
Houston and because of the relationship
that we built up with the business and
the key hiring managing the key decision
influences HR etc and the fact that they
saw as as as problem solvers a solution
providers not just brokers of TV's yeah
they were that they were comfortable in
giving us a chance to show our
capability in Houston yeah I'd say we
and how long did it take for you to just
quickly on that day have a time scale
but within five let me see yeah within
five years we were in Houston and
Singapore so it's a world would surround
what a year 18 months of sort of human
capital being known as problem solvers
delivering yeah then then gave them
confidence yeah yeah I can imagine
essentially what we did also is we
incubated those both the Singapore only
used the business from London from
London area working on projects in
Houston for instance we had a small team
in fact that the guy that note owns the
Coens of the business he brought it out
from me
Chacko and Paul Chapman he started like
he's based in Houston now he started was
in London he set up what was part of the
two two guys worked from our London
office for I want to say 9 to 12 months
working Houston hours yeah before they
then been there for a week I would go
over there for a week we do business
development we come back with one of
those projects he'd go over for another
week
yeah over fortnight and he go over for a
month and then eventually he went over
there permanently but he had a book of
business to go over with yeah that's how
we did it we you go into our multi you
find you find you find something that
you're excited you're interested in you
find companies that that you can work
with and my advice would be you
grow to reflect the needs of those
companies yeah and and then you try and
pick companies if you have ambition to
go international big companies the Utah
and foreign companies to work for that
have international operations yeah
so what what I'm really interested to
sort of dig a bit deeper on Justin is
the search piece that you're on about
this that we were known as problem
solvers not just bronnikov Seabees right
because I think we'll see now you doing
what you do I think recruiters that one
are gonna be build sustainable
businesses are going to survive through
this have to be known as more than that
they have to be known as solution set
though so just like when you say we had
a search process and we had the
refinement process and we were problem
solvers blah blah blah and I said what's
the difference and you said it's having
the rolodex of this and these sorts of
people but when you actually talk about
that let's just like lift like this but
actually say what you actually mean by
that because I think that's just really
beneficial because sometimes but when I
hear you I work for a search firm over a
recruitment agency I'm like oh what's
different from one understanding
conversations it's things like I don't
know like the actual set up where
there'll be a team of researchers that
do certain part of the process and this
what they have to do and the durn and
there's other people that just win
business or whatever but when you
actually say around this solution and
these types of things what what does
would that actually look like because I
think I'd be really useful for people to
know cuz I think that's what people are
gonna really be I think I think it's a
mindset
erm I think it's and it's a if you have
the mindset that excuse me that you're a
recruitment expert yeah almost like a
recruitment doctor yeah you're talking
to a client and what you're trying to do
is trying to understand what the issues
are what the challenges are what the
client wants yeah you haven't got your
recruiters hats on you're not haven't
got a sales have so on okay you've got a
consultative hats on and so you're
simply trying to understand what it is
they need what it why they need it what
they're trying to achieve what could
look like yeah
all this good stuff and then actually
you're assimilating the information
you're taking you're taking world all
that information and you are able to
then honestly advise them as to what is
the right solution for that organization
with regards to finding the person
they're looking to find okay and that
you have to go into that mock back with
the mindset that that might not be human
capital and it it might be that they
need to use a methodology that just
isn't the methodology that the human
capital would use they might it might be
that actually they don't need to do
research they should post an advert on
LinkedIn or they should go to a
different recruitment firm or they
should do something else there's not not
what human capital would do best for
them too many recruiters are full full
flat on their backs when a young see a
client and the client says look I need X
and their videos don't really what that
is I never done that but I don't really
know how to find that person but give us
a job
I'll do it we'll give it a go and and
they're desperate to get the job yeah
because yeah everybody wants dropped
everyone wants to have have a job I'd
love it exclusively I'd love it retain
wherever you want the job well I
understand that but the problem is is
that unless you're actually able to
offer them the right solution and be
able to deliver on that solution and be
able to put find the person they need
close that person have that person start
and to do a great job actually yeah you
are you are going to end up screwing up
that with that relationship with that
potential client and never been not
being able to work for them for maybe
forever yeah much better to go in there
and actually listen to what they're
saying understand what they need
identify what the using your recruitment
experience your recruitment know-how
identified the experience sorry the the
solution that is actually the right
solution for them
then advise them and if it's if it's you
and your company if it's human capital
fantastic we'll do that job for you but
actually if it's not we'll point you
actually will introduce you to the
company that you should be using hmm and
we took that approach and that approach
paid and still does pay huge dividends
so when you say you do it officially you
develop a partnership with you yeah
totally
and this is everything that USA people
talk about now and more recently right
when you say solution hmm like I guess
I'm just sore just probe in a bit here
because it's like okay just in the air
solution I get that but what what
welcome
when you say solution work how can it be
more than me finding you the right
person you know I mean what else would
part of that solution that made it you
know I mean is it market mapping I don't
know is it is whatever is right for that
clients needs but that's after we had we
could do certain things we could we
could draw upon our historical
experience so you know if it was a role
that we'd recruited before for a similar
company in the recent yeah we'd have
we'd have done the work yeah oh we would
never say we'll go and do the research
and charge you for that if we'd already
done it was a look actually we've got
this research done already okay so we
don't need to do that we can move more
quickly than that or it would be
actually we've got the international
capability so a lot of the work that we
did at uni after that was actually
moving people around internationally
okay these were specialist roles and you
you wouldn't just look in London for a
london-based role you might have to look
at Euston or Singapore or sure
relocating people yeah so it was a it
would be applying a consultative mindset
to in so that's what I mean by
commercial solutions if it was if it
turned out the role wasn't at the right
level for us or if it turned out the
role was in a function that we just
didn't have a capability in right now
and we didn't want a developer cape
and so now we would we would say win on
the right people then we didn't fit our
business strategy we wouldn't do it
yeah we wouldn't I will do it yeah we'll
do it because you know it'll keep me
feeling happy or we don't want anybody
else to be doing work for this client
will say yes to it yep in there were
times when we did in the early days and
that's how I learned not to do it was
that what happens is you end up you end
up doing in a harp you end up being half
a job you don't really want to do it
it's not in your wheelhouse it's really
hard work and actually you don't really
want to spin the the research off and
use it again you don't want to be on
that function yeah we learn to say no
yeah clients once you once you've said
no to a client no we can't do it we're
not the right people yeah you should
talk collects the degree of trust in my
experience goes through the roof
and events yeah ah it's you have a
different conversation because
unfortunately if we as recruiters we do
bear the scars as a group of of our
people who have trodden before us and
unfortunately recruit recruitment
consultancies accruing songs don't
always have the best of reputation of
course and and if you can if you can
differentiate yourself from the
recruitment consultant that always says
yes to a job but then does it before
gives poor service and do that by
actually being an honest advisor that
puts you well ahead of the game and
coming on to to sort of post covet and
and the the the the market that we're
going to be facing for most people in
improvement over the next few years
which is going to be a job short
candidate long market so not a lot of
jobs and yeah
it'll be the companies that have managed
to develop that consultative approach
with their clients that will be seen as
trusted advisors yeah a shot seen as a
solution providers that will be given
priority yeah definitely because I think
while is just pushing on the solutions
part Justin is because there might be a
lot of real crews listening right now
you think the only solution that I know
someone set-piece but will make the
decisions in their head the only
solution I can offer my clients is
finding them developers in this that had
this certain skill set do you know I
mean so I think that's what I'm just
proven you on that because I think a lot
of people make the decision if that's
the type of calm they're in or assume
that the only solution I bring to the
table as a recruiter is finding just in
the right person for this job
that's the only solution I bring and you
know see I have those conversations you
hear a lot more now about product
ization having different types of
solutions and I think sort of this
current period right now is probably
push that on a lot of people as well so
I guess that that's why I was just
probing you on that because I think it's
it's good that you're talking about that
and I think a lot of people have the
mindset that the only solution I have
and brings to the table is this which is
that I know yeah I mean yeah my advice
would be you know if if you haven't got
this capability already it's gonna be
difficult but a lot of agreement designs
are actually solutions white suits and
providers without realizing it it's
about you it's about the individual the
companies recruit with a methodology
it's about how how do you how do you
fill a job if all you know how to do is
take a job spec from a client
take your few boxes stick that on on a
on a website and then egg match match
Stevie's the job spec like that yeah
then I'm afraid you're gonna be really
challenged going forward because you're
adding no value so yeah to the world
over at Rubin and Ashley even without
covert your your
was gonna disappear in inversion yeah
computers can do that they can they've
done it they do it to a point now eh I
yeah if you can't if you can't add value
over and above just the objective
matching of series and job specs then
unfortunately gonna be dead in the water
so just quickly before we move on just
really simply what can that be then this
just like because I think it's just
important to make it really clear is
that as I said market mapping is that I
given a client an actual and an opinion
on what people think of their business
and I don't know what actual things can
I do as a recruit that isn't just that
thing in its maybe they have an opinion
I can't vote you're flying your client
says I need X don't just shake your head
and say I'll then find your eggs and
toddle off have a think about why do you
want X what are you trying to achieve
why why are you looking for that
particular developer while you're
looking for that particular skill set
what where does this all fit in what
have you done so far
why is that failed why are you
recruiting this position and ask all
those questions understand the situation
and then advise them on the best way to
do it to find this person advise them
actually this person doesn't exist they
don't exist tell them oh yeah have the
courage of your convictions you are an
expert you are there and your client
wants you to provide them with a
solution they don't want these provide
you provide them with just Seavey's they
want a solution they're one direction
they want advice they want to save time
they want to save money they want to bar
the best people and the right people and
if all you do is phone them up say yo
any jobs they say hopefully yes you say
what do they need ba ba ba ba ba and you
go away yeah you're just a broker you're
adding almost no value in my opinion to
to the recruitment process and
in a jobs or Canada law market you're
gonna be fine very very difficult to
differentiate yourself yeah agreed
clients who want to come to you rather
than to whoever else they talk to as
well okay okay so back to sort of the
human capital journey dem how did this
mindset how did this process well she
spoke a bit about how it gave you
international opportunities and so the
people that early early and early on
involved in that that nación and human
capital but how did then this actually
impact you growing this recruitment
business you could talk a bit about that
i've interesting how did this then
enable you to scale the actual business
itself well I mean the again scaling the
business was about eventually it was
about reflecting the needs of our client
base yeah so you said that if they
always with the gym cap has always grow
success successfully grown by
organically through reflecting the needs
of clients so and clients clients don't
always have exactly the same needs as
each other so you might work for BP
which is predominantly you know an oil
company but they have a small gas power
business or small LNG business for
instance and you do some work for them
in the LNG space which allows you to
then go and build okay you build the
capability in the energy space which you
then go and take to companies that only
do LNG or companies that do LNG but also
if we mess with metal gas or but also
coal yeah and you grow organically
yeah we'll always go from known to
unknown you don't dick to it so it's
about just what working your way through
a particular space mm-hmm then you've
got its 3d model so it's a matrix so
then you've got you've got you've got
sector or product then you've got
geography
and then you've got function so the
functions the Col function we know no
other roles yes it was traders but then
it was also marketers and sales people
then it was middle office staff so it
was accountants IT people as a
technologist analysts HR specialists
yeah all these are all people that work
in this particular sector which was the
energy natural resource sector so we
like this purely we never stepped out of
that we don't that I think the company
will ever step out of that it's about
just being one particular sector and and
in engine Natural Resources because it's
such a big space focusing on one
particular part of that which is the the
middle and downstream part of it so
human capital doesn't do anything in the
upstream it doesn't recruit people all
their hard hats and Henriksen yes it's
just the people who get it from the
beach to the shore and then from the
shore to the customer so to the yeah the
people that drive their cars or the
shipping companies in the airline and
see yes effect so I think it sorry to
the the trick the trick I think is
looking at what you've got thinking
right how can we maximize the return
here on what we've already got with this
what else do they do that we could do
for them that we could spin out and
increase and in doing so increase the
capability of our business which we can
then market to other companies which we
can then use to grow our capability
again again and again and again yeah
then you take it you look at you have an
international element to that which
allows you to expand as well and then
you have a functional element that I
think a lot of people get I think a lot
of people when they think of growth they
think it
to think about the other way they think
about it I need to get new clients new
business Oh No
yeah that's what I mean because that's
what you're talking about isn't that
yeah I mean it my holes the whole
strategy I don't know you share this
thought this this way of thinking is
like the whole strategy it's far easier
to get more business from an existing
client there is to break into a new
trial
yeah they maximize the return on what
you've got right now what you bought you
have access to if you put a great
relationship with an organization what
else can you do with for them because as
long as they know you to be a great
recruiter and not just the guy that is
great at finding X ways it developers
but they actually think this guy
actually knows how to find people to
know what kind of people so if you've
got if you've developed that kind of
reputation and you're known as that
solution provider as that recruitment
expert then use that to drive deeper and
deeper into into the company yeah that
what you then creates is a capability in
other functions other areas of that
business
other roles other maybe locations which
you can then spin out to other companies
yeah yeah totally I've seen one company
or a couple of companies and then spin
it out mmm
trying to and there are lots of
companies out there that do this but
it's such hard work to what we used to
call sure number so no phone a client
win a job for a job move on yeah I'm
fine either can't find another time
exists you're constantly having to try
and develop relationships it takes a
long time
relationships hmm okay so yeah I'm a
great believer in jennice a inch wide
mile deep yeah yeah now like that we
said about known into the unknown known
into the unknown I think that's that's
really called that I wanted you to talk
about that because I think a lot of
people do get caught in that don't they
that I build 250k this year and my
target actually is do 350 automatically
recruiters think that okay that means I
need 10 new clients that pay me this
rather than okay well I made 50k out of
this relationship can I make that into
another hundred you know I'm in because
I think I love the way that yeah you
that that that in my opinion is the way
to build a strong portfolio as an
individual recruiter and it's the way
ultimately that you build strong
recruitment companies it's not about how
many it for me when I go and see a
company you know one of the questions
are sis you know how many how many
projects that you work on last year and
and for how many clients and the
companies that say you know we did 1,500
placements for 1,500 companies I think
my god your people must be absolutely
not good haha that is so hard if they
say look we filled 1500 jobs for 500
companies that's pretty good I'd be
looking at it but I overlooking them
saying right well good stuff about 1,500
jobs for 1500 companies is imagine what
if you just got one extra job with each
of those companies yeah two jobs are
substandard companies 3000 jobs yeah
I'll get five out of out of 1,500 mmm
some 1,500 jobs you know it you don't
need to go and win lots of new clients
hmm you need to win some and you need to
be able to have a have a flow of new
clients coming through because of effect
yet life is life companies will stop
being clients for whatever reason then
what I've been probably nothing to do
with your business you just that
yeah their trains are moved out whatever
mmm you know RPO will come in and take
over whatever that yeah but you don't
you should it shouldn't be that you're
churning clients every every year so
when when did you start Keynes obviously
dig a bit more into obviously hive and
what you do now but just to sort of
segue into like when when did you and
your business partner actually you start
thinking
this is actually a business that we
could sell or exit WOC I think obviously
more back in the day way before eyes and
recruitment the typical mindset was
young and start recruitment business and
sell it I think some people still think
that that I can achieve van this OC but
there's a lot of things that people
don't understand or realize so I guess
when like what part of the journey did
you actually start thinking and
recognize well actually what we're
building here is actually something that
has got great ecstasy valium is
something that we could sell where where
was that on the timeline if there was a
moment was it was actually very close to
the beginning really yes because I've
worked in other companies and when I set
up HC I I knew that I wanted to build
something that wasn't just a Pearson
limited I am it wasn't about me I know
what was going to be important to the
businesses are off with jobs the only
employees start off with but yeah if if
the company was to have a value other
than the just simply the fees we made
and the profit were made I'm sorry if it
was to have equity value if my
shareholding was to be worth anything it
had to be more than me yeah I I knew
from the beginning that I needed to
build something that that wasn't relying
on just in person yeah wasn't ultimately
reliant on me and that had a brand value
of its own that had its own brand that
had its own that has in life and I
didn't know where that would end I think
if you asked me when I first started it
I would said he I want to sell it to
sorry I don't every recruiter doesn't
they start new business yeah I'm gonna
sell it if somebody asked me are you
gonna say I believe I really want to
sell it but I but I actually didn't want
to sell it but I just didn't know how I
was going to sell it but I did know
everybody else had wanted pie because
all I did was think I'll what kind of
company would I want to buy enough what
I'd want to buy company that you know
had a great database where everybody use
the database that's the important I'd
want to buy a company that was really
well run that you know had systems and
processes had accountants had a
marketing strategy implant had
technology have a lots of your stuff I'd
want to I'd want to I'd want to UM buy a
business that I mean I bought it all the
staff didn't walk out and go and work
for themselves
yeah we're a staff were loyal where they
were where they wanted to be part of the
company that had a strong culture that
had strong attention had a good people
plan so I knew all of that stuff
instinctively okay my think I think we
just said there though is and I'm sure
this is something that you ask people
now but what a great question that is
yeah well what type of recruitment
business would I want to buy yeah and
everything you just reeled off there
then coal vase the actions that you take
and what you want to build right but I
think everything he just reeled off
there or a great instead of saying I
want to sell this businesses did write
the correct question is actually what's
up recruitment business with all on the
by and so if you want to sell your
business
say you want to sell your business for a
million quid seven insulate whatever
22:24 third whatever yeah that's a lot
of money
yes missus sending your business 400,000
hundred thousand perhaps a lot of money
yeah if you think if you want to say
that is you know so for somebody to part
with their company for your business
yeah it's got to be worth its gotta be
worth something and it's gotta be it's
gotta have it can't just fall apart
the minute I take yeah yeah so what so
what was how long then with that a love
that thing that's great and we'll get
people thinking how long was that sort
of journey then to the point where then
there was people that wanted to buy you
guys out wanted to own human capital how
long was that process roughly
well we they were along the way
so I like many people startled thinking
that perhaps they're big companies that
might want to buy him yeah the future
and through a series of conversations
and just just about just research and
talking to people I realized that
actually for it for a search firm it's
quite difficult to sell a search from
because the perception is that the
equity value of that business goes up
and down in the lift
but actually the value of research firm
is the search console most people yeah
yeah
which to a degree anyone remembers any
yeah of course close but if you're if
you're building a room business my
advice is it's really important to have
great people but it's absolutely
imperative to have great systems
processes database technology brand the
other people will change and if if you
visit your only selling the people then
your the value you get will be much less
hmm there's a recruitment buyers whoever
they may be if it's private equity or
lending money to the management team
that's going to take over from you buy
the company from you or if it's an
another company they're not silly
they're not stupid
if they if they think for a second that
there's nothing holding this together
but sticky tape and string they're not
going to partner their money so that
then made you look at the other options
which was well it made me realize that
that actually the chances of a trade
sale were going to be quite slim also
what was involved in a trade sale was
not something that I was really that
enthused by yeah trade sales I haven't
come across one in many years now that
doesn't involve this trade sales in
involve what's called an in/out so you
don't just sell your company and to a
third party and walk away it's not like
selling a car you have to stay down deal
is you stay there you don't get all of
your money up front
they says basically take hits and yeah
basically try before you buy which is to
avoid the problem of the risk and
everybody walking out the next day
so you'll normally locked in for two or
three years post that and then that
again that kind of spoke to me about I'd
end up having another boss yeah and and
actually yeah all Tamale it just wasn't
going I didn't think it was going to be
an option for is anyway so I looked at
all the other options and and the vast
majority of businesses will be able most
of you man business isn't never gets old
so let's start there yeah they never get
to the point where they have an equity
value they never get to the point where
anybody would actually be interested in
paying money to to buy the business so
their Lord business don't achieve that
but those that do usually actually it's
through a form of management buyout it's
through the founder the owners or the
owner selling the business to the
management team below them the next
generation the next generation and
generate the next generation will do the
same and do the same yeah sometimes it's
financed by private equity sometimes it
might be financed for debt sometimes it
might be financed through the cash flows
the business okay it's fundamentally
about me and the individuals and sellers
but ultimately their internal deals that
happen I just say two key things on this
that I'd love to know and then let's let
the ginn to hive two key things first
one common misconceptions people have on
management buyouts yeah second one and
key sort of if I if I'm listening right
now I'm thinking actually this makes
sense
long term yeah I think I can achieve a
management buyout what what sort of
things do I need to start getting in
order to achieve that so I guess just
key key parts of that journey that sort
of you did and all learn
doing that they're really important to
make that a successful exit so common
misconceptions and sort of the key parts
that enable that to happen yeah I think
common misconceptions or
misunderstandings are around what is
American buyout for starters and on what
is in town and I think a lot of me out
you what do you look at is whatever
happens so you want somebody to buy your
company now if it's the management team
in some respects that should be easy
because they're part of it they can see
the value of it they can try it there's
trust there and they know what they're
buying and when it comes to push comes
to shove they're going to either have to
borrow the money to do that or they're
gonna have to you know finance it
themselves through their own savings or
whatever and that's when it becomes
actually becomes real
yeah it's a big big step for people to
do that if people - because even in the
primaries you deal with this game
they're going to ask the management team
advisor that their financing and their
supporting primary equities is there
just simply lending you money is very
expensive money and they're lending into
the management team to buy out the
current owners yeah and that that
probably business it's going to want to
know that the company that they're
lending this money to is a well-run
company yeah as an owner irrespective of
whether you're going to sell it to
another company or assert American team
or you're just gonna run it for cash
forever you want that business to be as
well run as it possibly could be and I
think what what people don't understand
necessarily and this is the
misconception is how you value a company
a recruitment agreement company so you
valuation of the recruitment companies
typically a multiple of profit of a bit
or even are whatever whatever whichever
a description of profit you want to use
but it's typically a multiple so it's a
number times the profit that the company
makes over a three-year period Africa
that's typically the formula may be
obviously there are many many ways to do
it but that would a good way to start
thinking like that so in order to
increase the value of your company and
to make more money from the sale of it
you you definitely want to work on both
improving the profitability of that
company the quantum of profit but also
you want to play around with that a
multiple you want to improve that
multiple and the example I would give to
anybody is like if you go a company
that's making a million pounds profit a
year yep
and you want to sell it if your company
can only attract a multiple of two
you'll make two million pounds you don't
have to mess around with the e bit
number anymore if you can move your
multiple from two to three or from two
to four three to five obviously cuz he
had two times - tube if you move it
three you double your multiple you go
from two million to four million then
you're going to understand what what
impacts the long-term what drives the
multiple and many many things try the
multiple almost none of them are to do
with whether you're great recruiters or
not they're do that they're all down to
how well run yes it's down to the
questions you earlier said yeah yeah so
I will I realized that pre pretty
quickly and and actually it's it's it's
even if I hadn't realized that it just
wouldn't have computed not to build a
business that had strong foundations and
strong system strong structure strong
processors as your business scales if
you don't have those in place you start
making mistakes you start losing money
you start yeah
well I know this is something that you
now have recruitment business owners
with right yeah no final thing just bit
crunches of time I never got like sort
of what 15 minutes or so yeah just a
final thing on that to tie that all
together
what for you has been the sort of
biggest positive out of going there MBO
route as a recruitment business owner
what ended up what do you soar Fink has
been the better rather than having the
stream in my ambition I'm setting
externally whatever but for you
personally what's been the biggest
positive out of going down that route
well it's a good question there's a
number different things there there's
there's actually the financials of it
are important and more important but
actually and then this is gonna so maybe
sent mainly sound a bit sort of it's a
reward but being able to to work with a
group of people and with two individuals
in particular who who I work with ever
since they joined the business graduate
trainees yeah to have worked with Damien
and Paul over 15 years and have talked
about obviously over that 15 year period
about the opportunity for them to take
over the business
yeah having been there as they they
married they've been a as they as they
built businesses both from Paul in
Houston Damien in Singapore and Natalie
London as they built their whole lives
to be able to work with them to build
something that has real value and then
to be able to pass that over to them for
them to take on their in their their
early 40s late thirties early forties
they now own that business or the vice
for driving they owned about 90% of it
yeah that's there's now to take to the
next level yeah and that you can't put a
price on that that's a really important
thing just
some people ya know I love that waiver
and I continue to support them and and
will do for it for every one a day but
there was that sort of it and then the
other side of it is going down the
mountain by out route you do have a lot
more control as the founder as the owner
has the CEO if you operational you do
have a lot more control on how that how
the MBO have actually works and and
mm-hmm and on on actually making it
happen but also on the timing of it the
valuation etc and actually that's not to
say that you think that you probably
will get more you probably would make
more on the valuation if you sold it to
a third party possibly yeah you know
typically yeah an MBA might be not quite
the most lucrative way to go but
actually what I felt when I did when I
did there
a taxi was that we were in together and
it was a positive experience and we all
wanted the deal to happen but we wanted
to do it in a way that was the right for
the company and right for the provide
for the employees but also vying for the
the exiting owner and the incoming onus
yeah awesome and yeah I think it was it
was it was a tremendous experience
overall and it's been I I would highly
recommend it and I mean any of any of
your subscribers that that have
ambitions to build something and and own
their own business I say go for it yeah
it's yeah it is my goodness is it tiring
and stressful and but it's super
enjoyable yeah and if you if you're if
the right mindset yeah only owning your
own business owning your own business
can be so rewarding not just financially
but also
in many other ways and you know I'm I'm
really grateful to to Kirstie that
recruits a Michael Page that has amazing
they saved me from a life of accountancy
on the track of so then Justin before we
finished just just really keen to talk
about hive which I think ties into this
really nicely in the journey that you've
been on I'll see obviously so x2 that
business I know obviously when we spoke
there just an element of luck right what
next
yeah and then obviously for I mean it
looks like obviously coming towards a
year now you've you started another
business called hives which as I said in
the introduction all about helping
working with McCrimmon business owners
recruitment entrepreneurs on actually
helping them scale their business and
building up the equity value which is
what he was talking about they're
increasing that multiple increase in
profit so that's what you've been
knocked over the sort of nearly a year
now I guess before we finish what I'd
love you just share because now you've
got this interesting perspective of
working with different recruitment
businesses and business owners what what
are what a being what have been the most
common pitfalls or common things that
have held McCrimmon business owners back
on building their XE value would you say
that's a big question in some respects
if I was shoes I think I think it was to
choose one one challenge that business
owners the founders of startups and that
face is it is the fact that when you
start a business up you are obviously is
the founder you're going to be crucial
to its success yes you're probably
probably do everything you probably you
probably bring client relationships with
you you probably bring can their
relationships with the main two coffees
you may the coffee's that were the best
person so going wing business the best
person to the right cetera
and many businesses never actually get
beyond that never get beyond yeah owner
is the person if the owner isn't there
things don't happen yeah and a lot of
that is actually down to the owners
themselves not being able to give up
their responsibilities their role in
neckline relationships not being able to
put our relationship not be able to give
up responsibility for making decisions
about the coffee the tea that yeah all
the computers yeah everything has to
flow through the owner yeah and
ultimately that owner becomes the block
themselves the bottleneck the bottleneck
yeah they they my voice would be watch
out for a situation where actually look
around to you and and there's nobody
nobody in your team in your business
that's challenging you hmm wanna hire
people that are better than you hire
people the better at that can a client
relationships come here client
development are people that are better
at delivery do you think recruitment
business owners want to do that no
because I think there's a there's a real
fear I think I think I think somebody in
line wants do I think them then I think
some learn to and I think a lot don't
because they are fearful of giving
people responsibility giving people
seniority giving people opportunity and
then those people leaving and going it's
competition of them yeah because that's
what they did yeah I don't want to
create another situation that they
actually were part of previously you
know they took so I think there is this
thing a lot of recruiters who set up
with your own businesses they're
recruiting businesses never get any
bigger than themselves
and a few other people who change
constantly because those those owners
never give up the the never give never
give their employees the opportunity
grow develop and build a business
themselves they hold all the
relationships so for instance the office
one is the prior relationships yeah you
that then why would good recruiters
George State but they might join you but
why would they stay with you yeah yes
yeah you're you're not giving anything
up I think my my experience my learning
is if you're gonna start a recruitment
business you want to look to make
yourself redundant from your role on a
regular basis and pass that
responsibility on to somebody else if
you were the if you're the key eye on
the 5/q relationships you've got the
main go on 5qe relationships in the
business how do you give those
relationships to other people so you go
away and build another five
relationships or yeah so you can go away
and build a business over here or do
this will do that you've got to give it
away
make yourself we're done in from that
and pass it on and then build a culture
of that so the person you give it to be
they then build they work those
relationships probably is and they're
looking to pass them on to somebody else
so they can do something else yeah this
it's I think that that's that's probably
the biggest challenge most recruiters so
has that been solve one of the most
common pieces of advice that you found
yourself giving then you really copper
vein these people to have the mindset of
finding constantly finding things to
make themselves redundant from yes yes
it's challenging it's challenging owners
why are you doing that why are you still
doing that who could do that who could
do that better why are you still doing
yep why are you still handling client
relationships yeah yeah if you want to
build a business that you can sell at
some point those clients can't be buying
from just a person limited they should
be buying from human so they should be
by do you need to do you need to know
that you want to scale your business
from the very start to successfully
scale it you think
I think most people starts a recruitment
business because they look at the
business they were working for the
moment everything I'm making a lot of
money for this company by only getting X
I'm a can walk yes yeah I think that
drives a lot of people to start off with
you know what does my current employee
give me you know I don't think he gives
me anything therefore I'm going to
endear myself so they I don't think
people necessarily most people start or
agree versus thinking I want to throw it
yeah beyond you know the normal yes of
course I want to grow yeah yeah but I
think I think there is if you're asking
is there a timeline is there a curve yes
I think there is I think the longer you
leave it the longer it is a Miss around
you is just in person limited the harder
it gets to change the culture of the
business yeah it becomes I mean there is
a way you're able to move in the
direction of growing everybody
interesting I think you've got to have I
think I think so yeah probably five
years it's probably the time if you
haven't thought about it and you wanted
to grow something now or never yeah yeah
so just quickly Dustin before we finish
interesting to get your thoughts on what
the future recruitment business looks
like I mean I'm sure you've looked at
the stats as you look to higher than
everything but there's various that's
out that the easily circa 30,000 we
recruit new businesses in UK the stats
that I've looked at anywhere between
sort of 80 80 80 percent of sort of
micro businesses are ups and nine people
yeah the next all banding up is there no
seed and 10 to 50 no again the huge
percentage and then I'll see kids going
up so I guess Weaver and Finn that's
gone on and everything how do you think
that what is the future recruitment
Bislett like does it is it a business
that scales to 40 50 heads and achieves
a MBO or is actually more knee
even more niche lean recruiting the
businesses to have great people's now
that are great what they do but it's
more liquid to other nodes you know I
mean I think cuz I think after honestly
don't know
yeah fair enough I think I think if you
are asking about the impact of
technology on recruitment
I think recruitment Technic technology
will change the role of the recruitment
consultant over time I think you'll see
where where recruitment is effectively
one-dimensional where it where it is a
body type thing we need you know we need
a we need ten people's gonna stack
shelves
I think that's increasingly will be done
just automatically through technology
um and I think that recruitment
consultants will need to recruit
obviously will continue to exist but I
think it will become more and more about
the added value element again in a
solution and it's about solutions about
I think I think technology will change
stuff in a world change the role of the
recruiter for the better in fact I think
I think you will it will make recruiters
become more consultative and more
advisory in the way that they operate
unless what around size that's not
always the best measure but I think
typically you typically I mean it's the
first question you get as a business
owner how many people of you are how
many people do you have Justin or how
many people in the business and also I
think it's typically been associated
with successfully a successful growing
recruitment business get fired yeah you
know like route 7
yeah I've never bought into that because
it's bloody easy to hire you meet people
miss out of it yeah when I used to meet
competitors or other companies when I
was a CEO and you know sort of comparing
in this you know we're a hundred men for
fantastic oh yeah I can build a hundred
man firm tomorrow
I can hire Andhra people whether they'll
make any money and whether we're around
the day or for me it's not about
headcount it's about productivity
productivity yeah the best company to
own is Warren whether you got the
highest productivity for a head and it
doesn't matter if it's if it's five
people there's ten people 50 people 500
people yes it's all about the
productivity per head and then and is
not just Billings you were found to
actually see what for me means
profitability for profitability I've got
caught yeah so I think I would never get
otherwise we don't don't get sucked into
thinking that success is hiring it's
having more people on desks what having
international offices and what having
offices all over the country it's far
easier to manage fewer people than more
people it's far easier to manage and
build a company if they're all sat in
the same location I'm trying to run a
business that is all over the world is
bloody nightmare
because yeah you've got time yet at
times owners logistics
yeah trying to build a company culture
across different countries very
difficult yeah so I think hats off if
you can do it but you know my advice to
entrepreneurs would be don't judge
success on the number of people that you
have in the office or in a company or
the number of locations you work for or
countries you're in judge it on how
productive your your business is how
stable it is how respected it is both
both Boyd clients Kansas and bye-bye
employees yeah don't don't get doing it
sucked into my head counts bigger than
your slip before we finish them what
what are you excited about with five
then I'll see early on
Jurnee what and what you most excited
about with that how yeah anything you
wanna shout about I think I think the
exciting thing at the moment is it is
the fact that for me personally is the
fact that I am meeting so many
interesting people both company owners
but also the experts that we that we
employ as hive that there are associate
base you know the the experts in ball
advisory the experts in marketing
technology they're all these people that
are part of the hive business and who
work with our clients to build their
businesses because it's not just me
there there are an increasing number of
us who are actually there providing
services to clients but actually what
I'm doing is is I'm just meeting a lot
of company owners and that's fascinating
learning about how they do things
learning about their companies what's
good what's not so good what their
challenges are and then meeting these
experts I mean yourself yeah we didn't
know each other know yeah that must be
really fun for you obviously and just
getting people learning and then being
able to make a difference yeah see
businesses that we are involved with
actually evolving and and growing or
dealing with covert it as we've had to
help out as well and getting through
that you know dealing with uncertainty
dealing with some really strange times
yeah it's it's it's very rewarding to be
able to do that and and really really
enjoy what that's that's that's why I'm
excited for the future yeah it's going
to be it's gonna be hard out there
that's not that's not good about it but
in there oh there are some advisors out
there that still seem to be sort of
banging the drum that this will be all
over by Christmas it's not it's going to
be very challenging for
for any type of business over over the
next few years but you know what it's
it's the challenge the we can meet those
challenges and recruitment companies can
still be successful in recessionary
markets and a recessionary market is
great because it gets you really really
fit yeah
and markets do come back and when
there's the companies that really push
hard to get fit and strong and healthy
for this next few years that we're gonna
go through they will find themselves
really well positioned when the market
ticks back up again and it will do I've
learned but over the unit would have
worked through a number of recessionary
periods and they are hard you don't earn
as much money as you did previously as a
recruiter or as an own or whatever but
you'll get fit and you'll be a better
recruiter or a better owner for it all
right now I think it's great what you're
doing and really excited to to see it
from afar and belit Justin been an
absolute pleasure really enjoyed that
just a big thank you yeah well thank you
very much I've really enjoyed it
thank you very much